Facebook trillion dollar company only
has 54 billion dollars in cash the same
as Harvard how the hell does Facebook
have the same amount of cash as Harvard
Tesla massive company only 18 billion
okay Disney massive company only 16
billion in cash how how so so so and
then they have the audacity to say
corporations don't pay taxes but no one
has the audacity to call call our
colleges while they pay this much taxes
March Madness zero in taxes football
zero in taxes they get away with all of
that and they get to charge parents more
money every year and pressure parents to
finance their house and take money out
you're absolutely right I think I think
the phase we are today people are
starting to realize and question
everything people like yourself people
like us were like dude I don't know what
the hell is going on but I'm questioning
and I want to learn more how the hell
does Starbucks only have three billion
how the hell does McDonald's have 2.3
billion in the bank and we got 13
universities out of 10 billion or more